Okay,
copy on a Tuesday and blog 10.
We made it.
Okay,
everybody.
Let's play.
What the fuck is going on in Europe
tonight?
Okay,
so sovereign debt,
also known as government debt is money
or credit owed by a central government
issue,
but it's also known as security.
Basically it's like me hitting you a
piece of paper and saying,
I want to borrow $1,000,000
for you and I'll pay it back in two
years.
Let's take a look at you.
Okay,
well dressed,
well spoken,
good looking.
Okay,
I'll do it.
I'll give you a million dollars,
but only if you pay me back a little bit
extra in return,
but I thought we were friends.
There are no friends in finance,
but okay.
How much do you want?
I want my million back plus three
percent.
A little bit about.
Okay,
where do I sign right here?
Governments do the same thing.
They issue sovereign bonds and accrue
sovereign debt.
Such bonds are usually referred to as
risk free bonds because if the
government can pay,
all they have to do is raise taxes and
print more money.
Ice Cream,
because governments never ever default
on their debt.
It's practically unheard of that a
government could ever,
ever,
ever get close to
you.
Hold on,
I'll get to you first.
Let's wind back the clocks.
On February seventh,
19,
92 presidents and prime ministers from
12 different European countries
assembled mess to read Netherlands
design the mess.
It was the document that led to the
creation of the European Union and the
implementation of a single currency
called the.
To join the EU countries needed to meet
strict criteria like no budget.
Deficits of more than three percent of
GDP.
Debt ratios of more than 60 percent of
GDP and interest rates on sovereign
bonds had to stay within two percent of
the EU effort.
Remember those numbers on January first
1999,
the euro was introduced in nonphysical
form.
Individual currencies like the German
mark or the Greek drama were locked at
fixed rates against each other,
making that insignificant subdivisions
of the Europe.
They had to get rid of three years later
in 2002,
the notes and coins of the yard were
printed and distributed and countries
started.
The process of exchanging all their
money for you,
why did they do it?
Why was the euro create?
Well,
you see,
most of the trade in Europe is among its
own country by removing exchange rate
risks,
cutting the cost of transactions,
encouraging firms to trade across
international borders.
The euro made the euro zone into an area
of monetary stability.
Data euro is the second most traded
currency in the world
behind the dollar.
Through renewed cooperation,
Europe sought not only to ensure
economic stability,
but the international peace and peace
they got,
but ha ha,
I thought my jokes were bad in Greece
where civilization itself was born,
things had been going awry for quite
some time after the switch to the euro
that traditionally strong Greek public
sector,
so wages rise to outstanding.
Not to mention that the retirement age
in Greece was very low and its benefits.
Very generous.
These things aren't enough to sink a
whole country.
It was ultimately tax evasion,
which did
the coastal suburb of Kubota.
He is home to Athens elite an apartment
here.
It costs more than a million euros,
but despite the obvious signs of wealth
efficiently,
only 16,000
Greeks declared an income of more than
100,000
euros on their taxes last year
when people in businesses don't pay
their taxes.
It limits revenue.
What the country takes.
When the money ran out,
atkins turned to other European banks
for loans.
Soon they owed billions of euro and the
debt kept going up,
but how to grease acquire so much debt
when the guidelines of the European
Union,
we're supposed to keep decks reigned in.
I'm going to make this pencil
disappeared.
It's hits
in 2010.
It was discovered that Greece had paid
banks like Goldman Sachs,
hundreds of millions of euro and fees
for arranging transactions that would
hide the actual level of borrowing.
This allowed them to keep spending it
accrue more debt.
Upon the inauguration of George Peppard
dre in 2009,
the Greek government revealed that it's
finances were far worse than anyone
expects.
Their budget deficit was 12 point seven
percent,
four times more than the euro zone's
limit.
The public debt was estimated at $329
billion,
144 percent of GDP and April of 2010.
Standard and Poor's decreased Greece's
debt rating to the upper levels of junk
status.
Junk Status Bitch.
Take a look at what happened to the
interest rates.
Have two year box.
Holy Shit.
Let's go back to that earlier
conversation,
but I thought we were friends.
There are no friends and finding well
with the EU.
That's not exactly the case.
By adopting the euro,
the countries involved basically agreed
that they would all be economic friend
and when the drunken indulgent little
brother passes out in the gutter in the
wrong part of town,
they're responsible.
Older brother has to see that he gets
home safe in times of economic emergency
countries can usually just print more
money and accept the inflation and
devalued currency that comes along with
it,
but the countries in the EU gave up the
right to print their own money,
so now they have to depend on one and
agrees is a relatively small country in
the scheme of things.
A little economy compared to German,
but when Greece owes money,
a campaign to Portugal and Portugal owes
money,
you can't pay to Spain and Spain was
when you can't pay to Germany,
then a problem arise.
It's the domino effect.
People fear it ripples through the EU
that can hurt comparatively stable
countries like France and Germany and
even the United States,
so Greece needs help to save the euro.
The other countries have ultimately
decided to bail out Greece on fifty
cents of every dollar that it owes way
to soothe.
It wasn't cheap.
You oughta know you bought it.
This in exchange for internal reform in
the way of harsh austerity measures,
no more early retirement,
reduced pay for public workers.
Large scale cuts to social programs,
higher taxes,
and a staggered repayment of the reduced
debt.
A lot of people in Greece think the
austerity measures are too harsh,
and so they've incited protests which
continue to this day.
The problem with the European debt
crisis is that Greece isn't the only
country in trouble.
How much Ireland owed
$865.
Billion?
Correct.
How much does Spain and Italy owed?
$1,000,000,000,000
each.
Correct who to mainly France,
Britain and Germany.
Correct.
And how Germany,
France,
and Britain going,
Roger will and struggling a bit of a.
correct.
Why?
Because they've been told these vast
amounts of money to other European
economies that can't possibly pay them
back.
Correct.
So what are they going to do?
They're going to have to bail them out.
Correct.
Where are they getting the money to do
that?
Roger is a good question.
The answer to that one.
How much does Portugal?
Oh,
hang on a minute.
What was the answer to that alien?
Just keep answering the questions,
Roger.
So
what is the longterm solution?
Most of the bailout money is coming from
the European financial stability
facilities.
Someone to make the efs as a permanent
fixture in the EU for whenever a country
is.
Some had suggested that the weak
countries lead the euro's to others,
that the eurozone should be dismantled,
complete,
whatever the solution,
whatever money's going to be put on the
table,
it's all going to be conditional on
serious structural reform within the
euro.
You hate to see a few bad seeds ruined
the party for everything.
If we don't deal with this now,
soon little at Germany here won't be
able to get a nickel for his grandma
from the cloud.
Let's not blow this out portion.
You think you could steal from us and
just walk away?
Yeah.
Thanks for joining us.
That's another edition of what the fuck
is going on in Europe.